water now they set to the screen Irving
against bullet oh nasty handles Irving
curls floats and scores Kyrie
beautiful
so cold and you said it look at bullet
stays in front active with his hands
he's got sides of everything is the very
end will flip let's see if they run it
to attack right on the catch no timeouts
but then that's Kyrie trying to get some
room for the win and got him at the
buzzer
[Applause]
there's Next Level and this is it right
there sure is
now it's Irving the tend to shoot they
have to build the lead back to 17.
Watanabe Smith
jumper
[Applause]
going up high every Irving just brought
the house down here in Brooklyn my
goodness look at that fence
I'm not sure this crowd is gonna recover
[Music]
Kyrie Irving driving on Melton and
this what a finish with the left hand he
hung in the air forever